what's up guys so as you know there is a
Robocop remake coming out soon and you
might also know that we here at the
screen junkies are not fans of it but
there is a labor of love a Robocop
remake called our Robocop remake and we
have some of the filmmakers and the
organizer of the project with us today
first he's the organizer of the whole
damn thing Dave Seeger thanks for being
here thanks for having me next these
guys have worked with Tim and Eric
Lonely Island they are the elusive fatal
farm
Zach Johnson and Jeffrey max hey fellas
hello and down on the end uh you know
him you'll love him he's the creator of
honest trailers Andy signor hey good to
be here on the panel for once let's get
the ball rollin and talk about the idea
of the remake it started with a
different film yeah I guess me and a
group of friends had always sort of
talked about let's try to remake a movie
scene for scene you know break it up
amongst a bunch of different filmmakers
we finally went into action with it with
Footloose miles ago when the Footloose
remake was coming out we decided okay
this is perfect so we pulled it together
for that and it was a lot of fun when
the Robocop remake was announced we
started fantasizing about let's do this
for Robocop and decided to pull together
yet
how many filmmakers were involved in the
project there's probably 50 50 something
different groups of filmmakers who are
yeah that's a lot to wrangle yeah it's a
lot of different groups of people before
we go any further let's throw clip from
the trailer of our Robocop remake 55
scenes by 55 filmmakers shed or Alive
you're coming with me
a crowdsourced remake of rowboat
we make
if anyone is going to ruin Robocop it's
us before we get too far ahead of it so
for our audiences clarification are you
trying to make a perfectly accurate shot
for shot remake no no I guess I mean the
idea with Footloose was take the scene
put whatever comedic spin on on it you
want establish the plot point keep the
characters moving so the story tracks
but really like it's sort of just
subvert us story beats and kind of
recreating the storyline in a different
way I want to talk to the fatal farm
guys you're seen it's so good test talk
to us about how you chose that scene for
some reason the best scene in the movie
or the best scene to recreate by our
opinion it was still up for grabs and
that is the rape prevention scene
graphic violence goes over well yes
someone's getting shot in the dick
what's more violent than getting shot in
the dick getting shot in 20 dicks to
give you guys taste let's take a look at
a somewhat censored clip from your scene
[Music]
yeah I wish we can make it more NSFW I'd
tell me how that worked it looks so cool
do can you break like like you cast you
cast a penis out of silicone you hollow
it out you fill a condom with blood you
stick it in there with a squib and then
you glue the whole thing onto some nude
underwear put them on and then you kind
of just pull down your pants and you
detonate the squib that's about that's
how you blow up a day and that's not a
danger to you wear a cup
I forgot I got that step actually until
about don't try it unless you have a
licensed pyrotechnician try it send us
the footage can I help
try min and Heidi oh great this scene is
yeah they shoot the scene when you see
this remake you know everyone's doing
their own version of the scene when
their scene starts you really think it's
the real scene from the movie and so
they're just they do it beautifully
- like rematch everything about it but
then it goes crazy and so it's this it's
as if the real Robocop movie had decided
what he's gonna blow off 15 dicks it was
genius
yes Andy I want to ask you how did you
get involved with this project the dick
scene was one we had considered
ultimately I sort of just I left Dave
sort of the resources like what's coming
up left is sort of what I ultimately did
there was a problem and no one could
really afford a convenience store it
seemed like and to pull that off
properly so were like all right well own
it will finally convenience store will
do it introduced Bigsby Snyder's I'd buy
that for a dollar it's the introduction
of Robocop so we did that we chose the
scene and I decided we're gonna do it we
should do it as a screen junkies piece
so everyone involved in our scene all
cast crew everybody including mr. Hal
Rudnick himself as our robber Nick Mundy
as our Bigsby Snyder
we really sort of embraced hopefully the
characters our audience has come to love
ya and else and really and have fun with
it
Andy let's let's premiere the screen
junkies clip yes let's go to the
convenience store take a look at it
movie that safe on the count of three
I'll blow your wife's brains
okay I'll open the safe you must have
good parents to raise such a good boy
your mama must have give you a kiss like
this give me a kiss on the lips you've
been open that on the count of three one
me drop the gun you are under arrest
aside from just being an awesome thing
that we are saying with this remake
something a little bit subversive to
Hollywood I think it's sort of like
trying to take the wind out of their
sails a little bit it's less being
really angry about it and pissed off
about it yeah I'm just kind of rolling
your eyes at it the Robocop remake
doesn't upset me that much because I
don't think the original Robocop is like
this you know undiscovered gem that
anyone's gonna forget about I kinda
streak as we recently just did a subtle
plug to our honest trailer for Robocop
yeah and the comments reacting to that
reaction is like the younger generations
like oh I don't want to see that Oakland
that looks stupid and cheesy like and
then they're gonna go up and watch this
new remake which I also have to say I
haven't seen it but reputa people told
me it's not that bad it's the second
best Robocop movie and he brings up an
interesting point
we here at screen junkies are gonna be
eatin a lot of crow if if this thing's
if this thing turns out to be like an
awesome action powerhouse what if it's
good what if I feel like I don't see how
it can be like I really like like from
what I've seen of the trailer and the CG
action and stuff like that like it just
doesn't look interesting to me at all
and that bone I have to pick about the
remake which I have to quote our amazing
director and editor Dan Merle yeah this
is out to me but Joel Kinnaman the the
actor who's playing Robocop has gone
record saying well I made sure my mask
wasn't on for most of the movie because
you can't act with half your face Peter
Weller went to [ __ ] robot school yeah
and having like he had a mime maybe get
all those movements down like what do
you mean you can't act with half your
face what is wrong with you of course
you can I think a good another movie two
references the recent Dredd movie Karl
Urban didn't show his face and it was a
reason take the mascot yeah yeah it was
something like let's stay true to the
source material and the character and
and what everyone thinks this needs to
be and so it's kind of just
they don't feel the same way about
Robocop having seen this Robocop remake
I can vouch that it is super awesome
how can people see it we're putting it
out before the the Hollywood remake so
that the world can see it
if you go to our Robocop remake com
it'll point you in the direction of
where you can watch the whole thing well
thank you so much for being here you
guys search out this movie click on it
see it it'll blow your mind it's so
awesome what movie would you want to
remake with your friends leave us an
answer in the comment section below the
best answer oh we're gonna send you
screen junkies t-shirt again I gotta
thank this super cool panel thanks for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
bye-bye I'm still holding out hope that
Justice League could be good but it does
seem a little bit like oh we got to
catch up catch up because you know oh my
god they're making another good movie
they're making a good movie they're
making a movie about a friend raccoon
and we can't even do Wonder Woman